E
TO DO THE REAL INTERFERENCE
THEMSELVES.
RACHEL: EXACTLY.
PETE: LET'S BRING IN NOW
REPRESENTATIVE KEVIN McCARTHY,
REPUBLICAN FROM CALIFORNIA,
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER HOPING TO
BE THE SPEAKER.
WE'LL ASK YOU ABOUT THAT IN A
MOMENT, MR. REPRESENTATIVE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST, ABOUT THE TWITTER FILES,
WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST TAKEAWAY?
>> IT'S WHAT WE FEARED BUT IT'S
EVEN WORSE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT GOVERNMENT
WEAPONIZING BUSINESSES TO GO
AROUND THE CONSTITUTION THE, TO
GO AFTER AMERICANS NEVER GIVING
THAT INFORMATION, THINK OF WHAT
80 FBI AGENTS COULD HAVE DONE
FROM HUMAN TRAFFICKING, FROM THE
KIDNAPPING AND OTHER CRIMES THEY
COULD HAVE SOLVED INSTEAD OF
GOING AFTER PEOPLE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAD NO RECOURSE, HAD
NO ABILITY TO GO BACK, DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW WHO WAS TARGETING
THEM.
BUT THE NEXT QUESTION DRIVES
EVEN FURTHER, WHAT ABOUT
FACEBOOK?
WHAT ABOUT GOOGLE?
WHAT ABOUT THE 51 INTEL AGENTS
WHO SIGNED A LETTER IN REGARDS
TO SAYING IT WAS, SAYING IT WAS
RUSSIAN COLLUSION WHEN IT CAME
TO THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP RIGHT
BEFORE AN ELECTION?
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT USED TO BE
THE HEAD OF THE CIA, THE
CLAPPERS, THE BRENNANS, THE
HAYDEN.
REMEMBER WHAT THE HEAD, HAYDEN,
HAD SAID.
I'LL PARAPHRASE, HE LITERALLY
CALLED REPUBLICANS THE GREATEST
NET OF TERRORISM AROUND THE
WORLD. -- THREAT.
THAT MEANS GOING AFTER YOU, ME,
YOUR VIEW ORS, 40% OF AMERICA.
AND THEY'RE USING OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT TO DO IT AND HIDING
THE FACT.
WE WOULD HAVE NEVER KNOWN THIS
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR ELON MUSK
BRINGING IT OUT.
RACHEL: RIGHT.
>> NOW WHAT CAN WE DO WITH IT?
WE'RE 17 DAYS AWAY FROM JANUARY
IF -- 3RD.
WE HAVE A PLAN SET FOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY TO COME IN,
MERRICK GARLAND TO COME IN AND
MAKE THESE ANSWERS, FROM JIM
JORDAN TO JAMIE COMBER, WE'VE
GOT TO GET OUR WORK GOING ON THE
VERY FIRST DAY.
AND THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU BRING IN
THE SPEAK ORERSHIP, WE'VE GOT TO
MOVE BEYOND THIS.
THE ONLY SHINING LIGHT IN THE
LAST TWO ELECTIONS FIGHTING
GOVERNMENT AND EVERYWHERE ELSE
WAS THE REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE.
WE WON BOTH TIMES WHEN ALL THE
OTHER REPUBLICAN ENTITIES HAVE
LOST.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
STRENGTH TO STOP THIS BIDEN
AGENDA AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THESE AND GET THE ANSWERS FOR
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
WILL: I KNOW YOU'VE MADE A
PLEDGE TO SUBPOENA THOSE 51
INTELLIGENCE AGENTS YOU JUST
MENTIONED THAT DISMISSEDDED
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP AS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
AND I THINK I ASKED YOU THIS
QUESTION WITH REAL HOPEFULNESS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THE FOCUS
OF THE FBI IS A POLITICAL
QUESTION, MEANING PRIORITIES,
DICTATING WHERE THE FBI SHOULD
BE PLACING, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
ATTENTION OF 80 AGENTS.
IS THERE SOMETHING YOU CAN DO,
IS THERE SOMETHING THROUGH THE
POLITICAL PROCESS THAT CAN THE
ACTUALLY HOLD IN THIS INSTANCE,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE THE FBI TO
ACCOUNT?
>> VERY MUCH SO.
THEIR FUNDING COMES THROUGH US,
THEIR OVERSIGHT COMES THROUGH
US.
THEY LIED IN THE PROCESS
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I'M PART OF
GANG OF EIGHT.
I'VE NEVER HEARD THAT THEY HAD
80 AGENTS GOING AFTER AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF.
IF YOU LOOK AT AMERICAN HISTORY,
WE STARTED SOMETHING CALLED THE
CHURCH INVESTIGATION BECAUSE OF
A SENATOR WHEN THEY HAD GOTTEN
OUT OF CONTROL, THESE AGENCIES,
DOING -- RUNNING AMOK.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT INTERNALLY.
WE HAVE OUR OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE RUN BY
JAMIE COMER, WE HAVE JUDICIARY
THAT HAS OVERSIGHT OF FBI WITH
JIM JORDAN.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT A SUBSET TO
GO IN.
THIS IS BECOMING SO DETRIMENTAL
THAT THEY'RE USING GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES, THEY'RE WEAPONIZING
AMERICAN BUSINESSES AT THE SAME
TIME TO GO AFTER AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
WE'VE GOT TO TURN THE IT ON ITS
HEAD AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
THE NUMBER OF WHISTLEBLOWERS
THAT HAVE COME FORWARD THAT
WORKED IN THE FBI THAT HAVE
GIVEN US THE INFORMATION, WE
CANNOT DELAY AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN START ON DAY ONE WITH THE
SUBPOENAS AND GET THE ANSWERS TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND MAKE THE
CHANGES NEEDED TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
RACHEL: CONGRESSMAN, PETE
HEGSETH HAS ON HIS ARM A TATTOO
THAT SAYS, WE, THE PEOPLE.
AND RIGHT NOW I DON'T FEEL LIKE
OUR ELECTIONS BELONG TO WE, THE
PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE THAT THE FBI WAS
INTERFERING IN OUR ELECTIONS IN
2020.
I THINK THAT'S SO SERIOUS.
AND AS YOU MOVE INTO JANUARY
3RD, HOPEFULLY YOU WILL BECOME
THE LEADER OF THE CONGRESS, WHAT
CAN YOU DO TO RESTORE PEOPLE'S
CONFIDENCE?
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T -- IF WE
BELIEVE THAT THE FBI IS WORKING
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY TO ALTER
ELECTIONS, TO HIDE INFORMATION
SO PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
INFORMATION GOING INTO AN
ELECTION, THIS, I MEAN, WE HAD
FOUR YEARS OF INVESTIGATIONS
OVER RUSSIA, SO-CALLED RUSSIAN
INTERFEERCHLTS WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN?
>> WELL, A NUMBER OF THINGS ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE HAVE AN ENTIRE PLAN.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID WHEN THEY
WEAPONIZED THE INTEL COMMITTEE.
NO LONGER WILL ADAM SCHIFF OR
ERIC SWALWELL SERVE ON THOSE
COMMITTEES.
WHERE THEY TOOK A COMMITTEE AND
MADE IT POLITICAL WORKING --
THIS COMMITTEE HAS THE OVERSIGHT
OF ALL THESE AGENCIES, AND THEY
DROVE IT.
YOU'VE GOT THOSE IN THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, THOSE 51, YOU'VE GOT
THEM WEAPONIZING EVERY OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA NOT TO PLAY THE NEW
YORK POST ARTICLE WHEN IT CAME
TO HUNTER BIDEN.
AND REMEMBER, THIS IS IN A SHORT
TIME FRAME RIGHT BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
ALL OF THAT HAS TO COME FORTH.
TO KNOW THE TRUTH SO IT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
AND THEN FOLLOW THE TRUTH TO PUT
IN ANY SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE SURE
OUR ELECTIONS, THAT THIS CAN
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN, THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC GETS ALL THE
INFORMATION, AND THEY CAN MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISION SO WE, THE
PEOPLE, CONTROL WHAT IS
HAPPENINGMENT.
PETE: IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
RACHEL'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
REAL QUICK, THE D.C. BELTWAY
PRESS IS ABUZZ ABOUT WILL KEVIN
McCARTHY BE THE NEXT SPEAKER.
WE'RE TOLD THERE ARE FIVE OR SIX
MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
THAT ARE THE HOLDOUTS AND
THEY'RE DEMANDING MOTION TO
VACATE WHICH MEANS THEY COULD
TRY TO VOTE THE SPEAKER OUT AT
ANY TIME.
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS INSIDE THE CAUCUS?
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M VERY CONFIDENT.
LOOK, I'VE BEEN LEADER FOR FOUR
YEARS.
IN THE BATTLE THAT WE JUST HAD
FOR THE LAST TWO ELECTION
CYCLES, WE'VE WON THE MAJORITY.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO STOP
BIDEN'S AGENDA.
WE HAVE THE MAJORITY AND WE
FIRED NANCY PELOSI.
NOW WE'VE GOT TO GET OUR WORK
GOING.
THE CHALLENGE HERE IS WHAT THEY
WANT IS A MOTION TO VACATE MEANS
EMPOWERING EVERYBODY.
ERIC SWALWELL COULD COME TO THE
FLOOR EVERY TODAY TO CHALLENGE
WHETHER THE SPEAKER CAN STAY IN
THE OR NOT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
STRENGTH TO DO THE JOB IS, TO
LOOK INTO PLACES THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO WANT US TO LOOK
INTO, TO HAVE THE SUBPOENAS TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE OUT, TO BE ABLE
TO SECURE OUR BOARD OR.
HERE WE ARE JUST A FEW DAYS AWAY
FROM TITLE 42 BEING LIFTEDDED.
IF WE DON'T GET THE SPEAKER
SITUATION SITUATED NOW, WE'RE
DELAYED IN ALL THESE PLANS AND
ACTIONS.
WE WANT TO HAVE HEARINGS DOWN
ALONG THE BORDER SO THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY KNOWS WHAT'S HAPPENING,
AND THE DEMOCRATS CAN NO LONG OR
HIDE FROM IT.
THE CAMERAS CAN SHOW THE
PRESIDENT IF HE WON'T COME DOWN
THERE.
WE'LL HAVE THE POWER OF THE
PURSE, THE APPROPRIATION
PROCESS.
WHAT THE SENATE IS DOING TODAY
WITH AN OMNIBUS IS WRONG.
PETE: YEAH.
>> THEY'RE EMPOWERING --
PETE: WHY IS MITCH McCONNELL
DOING THAT?
RACHEL: HAVE YOU CALLED HIM?
>> NOT ONLY HAVE I CALLED HIM,
HE'S GOT TWO SENATES OVER THERE
THAT WILL NOT -- NO LONGER BE IN
OFFICE IN 17 DAYS WRITING THIS.
WHAT WE SPEND ON THE VERY
BEGINNING, $100 BILLION MORE
THAN WHAT'S NOW.
THEY'RE GOING TO LOCK IN
DEMOCRAT WOKISM.
WHEN YOU CAN WAIT 17 DAYS AND WE
COULD HAVE MORE POWER.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO IN
APPROPRIATION BILLS?
WE CAN PUT LEGISLATION IN THAT
CHANGES AND SECURES OUR BORDER,
HELPS US BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, LETS PARENTS HAVE A
SAY IN THEIR KIDS' EDUCATION.
WATCH WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO THE
WHEN WE FIRST AFTER THE ELECTION
TO LIFT THE VACCINE MANDATE FOR
OUR MILITARY, TO MAKE SURE THE
PARENTS AT DoD SCHOOLS HAVE A
SAY IN THEIR KIDS' CURRICULUM.
WE HAVE SHOWN FROM THE IF VERY
BEGINNING AFTER THIS ELECTION
SOME OF THE VICTORIES WE CAN
HAVE.
WHY WOULD WE LOCK ANYTHING IN
WITH THE DEMOCRATS?
AND THINK ABOUT IN THE, THE
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE, THE
SENATE AND THE PRESIDENCY.
THEY DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB.
WHY WOULD THE REPUBLICANS HELP
HEM DO THEIR JOB NOW BEFORE WE
HAVE A STRONGER HAND TO PLAY AND
THE GAVEL IN 17 DAYS?
PETE: IT'S TRUE.
IT'S INSANE THAT MITCH
McCONNELL WOULD RATHER WORK
WITH NANCY PELOSI THAN HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ON AN OMNIBUS BILL,
LOCKING THINGS IN WHILE THEY
STILL HAVE CONTROL.
RACHEL: IT EXPLAINS A LOT --
PETE: IT DOES.
RACHEL: -- ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE TRUMP RULES, FRANKLY,
WITH MITCH McCONNELL.
WILL: CONGRESSMAN Mc